so before we get into the new single of
course before we get into the record I
have so many questions let's talk about
house I thought isolations going you
look very comfy right now
yes I mean it is really strange this is
such an awesome time for us like the
first single of the new era and so we're
basically promoting everything from home
and yeah it's so strange I'm kind of
still trying to get my head around it
all but yeah I know I feel like
sometimes I wake up and I'm like is this
real life yes this is real like I know
like I get this wig and wake up and I'm
like no what no is it strange that you
can't see Perry Jesse and Jade on the
regular like you talk to them a lot yes
so we're talking constantly in our chats
and our whatsapp chat so yeah but yeah I
mean I miss them so much
I just want to be able to go and work
with them and just me house and just
know that I'm gonna see them like we've
seen each other every day
so yeah would have I been seeing that
you're doing some chick talk videos are
you addicted yet kind of yeah I think
it's something different because
obviously we've had Instagram and
Twitter so long and - but like we
absolutely love doing silly videos
anywhere that we've always kind of done
that so it's actually had a platform
where it's just spaced on I don't know
video dancing or whatever you want it to
be I think it's like really cool so yeah
it's good you're very good at watching
your videos I love them I know all right
so let's talk about breakup song how has
the reaction from the fans been so far
oh good yeah and we were so excited for
this songs it's definitely one of our
favorites quite possibly one of my
favorite single releases we've ever had
I just loved it so much yes a big
statement I know um so yeah to see the
fans react the way they have it's just
been amazing like some of them are
saying that it's their favorite lyric
song ever and I can't remember that
reaction since like shout mix so yeah
it's really good really good what's the
message that you hope fans take away
from this one well I think obviously
it's such an uncertain time at the
minute and to have a song that just puts
a smile on people's faces and it's
lifting and I hope that it can just make
you smile reeling that's what I like
about it because you know there's we
love our breakup songs some are sad some
are upbeat but this one feels really
positive and I feel like I really want
to rock out in maroon when I listen to
this song yeah exactly
and I think that's what is so special
about it it's it's like a happy sad song
so obviously it's about something like
quite sad but we flipped it on its head
and why you say when you listen to it
you just want to smile you just want to
dance around and kind of celebrate the
fact that you're doing your thing and
even though you've gone for a breakup
you're good
you're going to be okay now is it true
that the original music video for this
you were supposed to shoot that in
Brazil and then of course with cover 19
back to the backseat now when this is
all over do you think you'll you'll film
an alternative version of the video are
you happy with with what you have
oh yeah we've got a look menu out of the
minute and which is really cool and then
we are currently working on a video so
yeah it's gonna be quite interesting
something we've obviously never done
because we're having to shoot bits from
home but yeah I think I'm hopefully the
fans will love it we didn't wanna just
do a video that we weren't going to be
in so we're gonna use our imagination
and yeah we've got something coming so
now what can you tell us about the new
album because you know your fans are
just so excited yes so the new album
this kind of came together quite easy to
be honest it was quite a nice process we
didn't put pressure on ourselves and we
can't just sort of just went with the
flow sort of thing and whatever we loved
it's going on that makes sense so it's
not like we've and over forty of
anything like we've just got really good
pop songs on there so yeah we're excited
for this one it's a big it's a big album
because I it's not 7,000 it's English or
is on six album it's pretty surreal that
we've had so many so yeah we want to
make this one a really good one
you know now is the sound gonna feel a
little bit different or is it just
you're saying a lot of good pop songs
yeah I think of the m5 was a little bit
more cooler bit more R&B on there which
we love because it's more music that we
love to listen to but for this one I
think we've kind of like I don't know II
feel like glory days album it was all
about the production and there was a lot
of pop bangers on there and I think the
fans loved that yeah
so with Connor maybe murder - a little
bit m5 glory days bit more on the pop
sides just bangers yeah yeah I know that
you guys have covered some pretty
important topics in your previous albums
from the Miche movement in woman's world
and of course
in songs you know embracing self-love
and songs like strip are there any other
important messages that we can expect to
hear in the new album oh I think the one
thing that we do love about our music
because it is always inspiring like we
what we love to inspire our fans
definitely so I don't think we'd ever
lose that I'm trying to think of a
certain one hmm
there is one someone there there is like
quite a performance someone you can
imagine it being like the opener that or
something yeah and it's all about just
kind of not giving up and just going for
it and that's all you're getting of your
big summer tour that's supposed to kick
off in June you know what that's still
happening right so the tour and that's
now how to haven't be pushed back yeah
unfortunately but it's definitely so
happening everything is still going
ahead but it's gonna be postponed
no anyway is what it is yeah well it's
everyone's making right decisions you
know right so everyone tells us
self-isolation is over and that we can
continue with their lives yeah exactly
are there any collaborations but you can
tease us with for the new album or any
any artists that you'd love to
collaborate with because we just loved
your collaboration with Nicki Minaj oh
we haven't had any out of yet but I
really want to collab with a Latin
American artists like bad bunny just
something really sexy and yeah Latino II
yeah obviously Ariana that's like a
dream yeah but I'm sure we'll have some
exciting ones coming up for sure very
cool okay so what is the first thing you
want to do when self isolations over
oh how big oh I just have social contact
um I think just go out and go for an
amazing dinner see all my friends you go
celebrate on how well the singles doing
and yeah just have some drinks and just
be with people and I think that's it I
feel like nobody wants anything big we
just want to go out and go to dinner or
grab a drink just because yeah
yes definitely are there any movies or
TV shows that you are addicted to right
now or any suggestions you have for your
fans to watch oh okay watching so the
minute me and my boyfriend are watching
me think will save me mmm it's on the
sky it's amazing it's so good it's one
of those ones where you're just as
you'll see yeah but really good what
else Netflix I watched everything I know
the problem I feel like I keep watching
flea bag season two like over and over
again um Elite hey if you had a fun yes
it's so good yeah have you seen it I've
seen first two seasons okay yeah really
really good loved that and then have you
seen Invisible Man it's a film oh my god
so good yes it's so much twice yeah it's
a maze of there oh my god yeah creepy
right Oh creepy but then really
empowering by the end
yes exactly well thanks for chatting
with us and congrats on the new song
it's so good and I can't wait for the
new album thank you so much so talk to
young lovely talking to you too